on ouvre une page politique à présent
c'est acté depuis lundi les élections
départementales et régionales seront
bien maintenue en juin malgré un report
d'une semaine pour les différents partis
il faut désormais désigner des
représentants
chez les républicains d'indre et loire
les élections internes ont déjà eu lieu
on en parle tout de suite avec le patron
de la droite tourangelle
bonsoir fabrice bagarre bonsoir autres
échouent a fini vous êtes le patron de
la droite tourangelle vous avez été
fraîchement réélu à la tête de la
fédération à départementale vous étiez
le seul candidat en même temps qu'ils
payent trop de suspense il ya eu
effectivement vous le dit j'étais le
seul candidat mais permet tellement
avant d'aborder les sujets et notamment
celui ci dans le détail j'aimerais
penser à mes aînés mes prédécesseurs
tous celles et tous ceux qui ont pris ce
poste en main en tant que président de
la fédération départementale les
républicains avant l'ump et avant le rpr
et j'aimerais avoir une pensée pour eux
parce que je pense qu'il ya un peu de
avec moi aujourd'hui et j'en suis très
fier on apprend toujours de ses de ses
aînés on apprend toujours de ses aînés
de ses prédécesseurs c'est clair dans un
peu plus de deux mois se déroulera le
scrutin des départementales et des
régionales il fallait donc choisir des
candidats
on va les découvrir avec vous ces
candidats de la droite alors jérôme
tebaldi pourtour claude greff pour
amboise louis tous les éloges
judicaël ossements à chinon et philippe
briand à sortir il ya des noms qu'on
connaît bien sûr avec la vieille garde
un claude greff philippe briand des plus
jeunes aussi un petit mot sur lui tous
les cons connaît peut-être un peu moins
alors louis tulle et le délégué de la
troisième circonscription il a été élu
brillamment
effectivement nous retrouvons claude
greff nous ne retrouverons aussi
judicaël hausse - qui a été élue
déléguée sur la 4e circonscription
philippe briand et c'est un homme vous
le savez avec qui je travaille depuis de
nombreuses années je suis également sont
élus à saint-cyr-sur-loire j'ai beaucoup
de plaisir être à ses côtés claude greff
qui est ministre il faut le rappeler
aussi et qui anime brillamment la 2e
circonscription et jérôme tebaldi qu'a
remporté l'élection sur la première
circonscription de là il y avait trois
candidats comme judicaël osmont sur la
quatrième il y avait trois candidats
il ya une bataille un petit peu ou pas
sur quelques circo ça s'est fait quand
même dans une bienveillance
je pense qu'on avait veillé à ce que ça
se fasse dans la sérénité la plus totale
et la bienveillance également qui
convient dans ce type d'élection
évidemment tout a été fait de façon très
transparente nous avons la chance grâce
au fait que nous ayons construit son
plan national de voter électroniquement
donc tout cela s'est bien déroulé
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui étaient
appelés à pouvoir le faire l'ont fait à
travers des boîtes électroniques
smartphones tablettes etc etc y compris
nos aînés parce que tout à l'heure je
vous parlais des aînés les pigments dans
un parti politique
nous avons tous les âges de représenter
et nous avons des jeunes effectivement
les moins jeunes et ceux qui nous ont
accompagnés auparavant et tout cela
s'est déroulé grâce au fait que nous
ayons une assistance hotline national et
local tout cela dans les règles un parti
sur le plan sanitaire et je peux vous
dire que la fédération d'indre et loire
a participé à hauteur de 66% contre 61%
au national ce qui veut dire que nous
avions je pense bien construit des
choses et je remercie le secrétaire
départemental qui est mathieu le marié
qui a beaucoup oeuvré pour faire en
sorte que ces élections soient pour
chacune et chacun oeuvre et de sérénité
et à peu près 850 en adhérant
effectivement nous avons près de 13
cents adhérents dans le département et
la liste électorale était composée
d'environ 850 personnes qui elles
étaient à jour de cotisation parce que
les règles sont les règles soient sont
les statuts nationaux alors au niveau
des régionales pas de surprise on
connaît déjà le candidat c'est nicolas
forissier
selon vous est-ce que c'est la bonne
décision de maintenir ces élections vous
me parlez du vote électronique
justement est ce que ce serait pas une
solution justement pour faire plaisir à
tout le monde je pense je pense que le
vote électronique est à mon avis
l'avenir
néanmoins nous avons je dirais eu des
élections qui ont été reportée
successivement nous devions aller à
l'élection en mars nous avons été
prévenus que nous irions en juin et nous
avons à nouveau été prévenus vous
aurions une semaine supplémentaire c'est
un peu dérisoire quand même c'est ce
report d'une semaine pour ma part je ne
comprends pas ce que le gouvernement a
volé deux comme message là alors que on
le voit depuis une année
nous avons des règles sanitaires
respecter nous avons des organisations
fort bien faite au titre des
municipalités parce que on le sait si le
gouvernement n'avait pas eu les élus
territoriaux les élus locaux les maires
en particulier toutes les acteurs des
territoires pour réussir ce pari
concernant jeudi
la crise sanitaire nous ne serions pas
là aujourd'hui ces maires ruraux ils
n'étaient pas ruraux 1 je dis bien il
n'était pas en faveur du maintien de ces
élections à six parce que l'autre et
loire a voté en majorité enfin à 52%
contre 40,8 me semble-t-il retrouvé les
maires ruraux étaient pas forcément pour
oui mais une grande majorité était pour
parce que lorsqu'on sait que nous allons
vous et moi faire nos courses au
supermarché
tous les jours lorsqu'on sait que nous
déplaçons dans les magasins dits
essentiels du reste il faudrait parler
de l'essentiel non essentiels néanmoins
je pense qu'on est en mesure en mairie
dans toutes les mairies de france et en
particulier en touraine d'organiser ces
élections dans le degré sanitaire requis
il faut les il fallait les mois il
fallait les maintenir la démocratie
j'irai importante il ya nombreux pays
dans le monde qui ont assuré pendant la
crise notamment l'allemagne des pays-bas
les etats-unis bien d'autres chefs qui
aura moins de gens qui viendront voter
commenté nous réaliserons peur oui mais
je pense qu'il faut l'être assurant sur
cet aspect là nous avons la mesure qui
convient nous avions eu une expérience
en 2015 ans en 2020 pardon mais là nous
avons appris je dirais durant cette
année
et puisque ont confié au maire le fait
d'organiser je dirais les scolaires
d'organiser l'accueil ses terres et
c'est pourquoi ne pas envisager
d'accueillir les élections dans le degré
qui convient et moi je tiens à rassurer
nos concitoyens tout se passera bien dès
l'instant où évidemment la distance sera
requise le port du masque évidemment le
gel avec le gel hydroalcoolique etc etc
mais à mon avis tout ira bien et puis en
plus nous avançons avec la vaccination
donc là il n'y a pas de difficultés si
jean sera le gouvernement dernière
question monsieur bagarre pour une autre
une autre élection celle de la
présidentielle l'an prochain on en parle
déjà forcément les déjà des noms qui
sortent
xavier bertrand qui est candidat
officiel peut-être un retour de nicolas
sarkozy on sait pas françois baroin
valérie pécresse laurent wauquiez avant
le favori pour l'instant je n'ai pas de
favori
et pour ma part pour ma part je ne vous
en parlerai pas aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est parce que c'est pas le moment le
moment aujourd'hui c'est de se
concentrer notamment sur les actions qui
viennent et des chansons vous venez de
parler régionales départementales
inscrit dans cette union deux de droite
et du centre qui pour nous est important
me semble-t-il et faire en sorte de
rassembler autour de nos idées nos
valeurs et c'est à mon avis que nous
aurons à faire dans les prochaines
semaines voire les prochains mois
ensuite après vous me parlez de
présidentielle
il y aurait effectivement cette étape là
elle est il appelé jce latif qui devront
ensuite mais je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir vous voir être
pouvoir en parler à ce sujet voilà merci
beaucoup francis franck fabrice pardon
fabrice boé gare excusez-moi difficulté
merci à vous de m'avoir accueillie